[Music]
hello nice to see you oh it's a it's a
lot of people in the room today I will
be talking about improving customer a
classification accuracy of customer
contact transcriptions I work at KPM a
data science step and part of text
analytics group we are doing a lot of
interesting research and text analytics
and I will give you some insights on
what we have done so far and work we can
proceed with that so yeah I will try
I'll do my best so I've kept the end
they have a lot of customer contacts and
I received 7 million service calls per
year and around 700 thousand chats it's
only for copy and a consumer brand and
also we have Telford and other brands
with a lot of customer contacts there as
well calls and chats are expensive so
reducing customer contacts is an
important target for our business
stakeholders right now we have some type
of categorization in place and all chats
and calls are being categorized manually
so we have codification 3 3 with 3
levels on the first level we have some
categories 70 categories on the second
level and approximate and more than
400,000 categories on the third level
that's huge a lot of different
categories in there and manual call and
chat classification is being used to
spot issues that affect a large number
of customers and therefore it's
important to monitor what's happening
out there and whether some kind of
course there is anomaly in it
manual classification right now has lot
of problems so many calls and chats are
not being categorized at all and agents
not particularly motivated to to do
their job correctly so therefore we were
asked to help out and at least
categorize the calls and chat which we
couldn't could not be categorized by
people so if we look at the categories
three levels and that's the first level
yeah it's I wouldn't go through all of
them but if we just briefly read what's
in there we already spot some problems
so there are two groups like payment
prepaid and tariffs and billing and
tariffs use they seem to be overlapping
it's okay but we know that issue
also there is report disruption report
disruption TV these are topics defined
by the business there is clearly overlap
between them because yeah you can have a
problem with internet and television at
the same time where would you put such a
call in which category it's not clear so
let's zoom in into some of these first
categories and look at the second level
so there is order delivery payment
billing and inside of this we have some
other levels and we also spot the same
problem mechanic and mechanic
appointment is in two different first
level categories and it's not clear in
which we should put a call or chat the
same is with damage loss and reparation
these are two different places where
such a colon can be put in so humans can
easily misinterpret or a being can be
confused in where to put the caller
child so this is an issue we know the
same with installation hardware but
nevertheless we had already some data
label data we had 180,000 labeled call
transcripts and 40,000 labeled chat
transcripts and we just decided to start
from there so why not to try it try
different kind of supervisor algorithms
to try to predict these categories so
it's a naivebayes
some baseline algorithm we tried CNN
it's a similar turkey owns convolutional
neural network for sentence
classification we modified that model a
bit I will show you a bit later how it
looked like
lsdm and hybrid models CNN with a less
cm layer on top of it and we compared
the performance of base of the model to
two things
agents accuracy what's the human
accuracy for this task and accuracy of
CNN on Amazon reviews so Amazon reviews
is a pilot project we did before
we gathered the Amazon reviews from
internet that belong to different
categories
like baby food cosmetics many many
categories out there and there are also
subcategories so we were trying to
predict product category and subcategory
based on the review of a person and we
wanted to compare the performance to
that one so if we look at the example of
the data we have this is a child this is
a nice example of a chat actually
everything is in Dutch but I translated
this particular example into English you
can try to read that the idea of this
chat is that someone wanted to cancel
subscription then they had a contact
with retention desk and in the end they
ended up buying extra products that's
exactly what we want to have this
happens and basically this goal this
chat was crucified in cancellation
cancer subscription because each call
and chat is only classified as one to
cut into one category clearly this is
not about one category there are
multiple categories out there and this
is this award to belong to consolation
but these words belong to order and
subscription renewal this is only a part
of chat this chat wasn't longer than an
hour and in the end we clearly could see
there was a new order placed for a
mobile subscription so there are
basically three things happening with
only one tag so it's not only that cost
across is a misleading there is another
problem that one conversation goes about
multiple things when there is only one
label available so if we look at CNN
architecture you can take a look at the
block on the paper of I mentioned here
we took the basic idea from here and
modified it a bit so basically the text
we have welcome you're having chat with
yup we can we can take this string and
create a water bedding matrix which is
which a size size of the chat by number
of embeddings and then apply apply
convolutions on top of that three in
parallels so we have three words we are
looking in the sequence four and five
and then we use max pool
and join join these results and have
hidden layer and apply softmax we have
two categories who trying to predict
simultaneously the first level in the
second level and we have some penalty on
if there is a second category predicted
which doesn't belong to the first
category and there is also an ifs
information we have our chat and per
word like if this word was pronounced by
agent or client we also have information
about products that a customer has it
kpn and some other information what kind
of contacts he had before so this
information can be added information per
word can be added in word embeddings
layer and information firm per document
can be added in the joint layer as an
extra information that actually improves
performance a bit so if we compare the
results of the performance of the model
to the baseline we defined so enamels in
product reviews it's and the performance
was quite nice it's 88% and 65% on the
second level for the chat data we got 65
and 50% and the cold data is a bit
disappointing it's only fifty one forty
percent so the reason is that
performance is differs so much there are
multiple reasons first of all custom
interaction data is more complex and
every review data in the review you have
one person that tells something about
the review in a conversation you have
two people so the style of conversation
differs also custom is likely talk about
different problems in the same chatter
call but in the review there is yeah
there is likely only one product that
described people don't often compare
things to each other in the review and
the custom interaction is longer so in
our model we assume that the length of
chat is a 1/2 thousand if the length was
shorter than 1/2 thousand we added no
word placeholders due to the chat to
make it one half thousand or we
removed some words if it was longer and
for cold transcripts and we see worst
performance and the reason of that that
we decide transcripts so there is
inevitable loss of information when we
actually transcribe the data and it
effects the performance drastically for
the rest engines are the same everything
is the same and also labeling quality
significantly worse than Amazon data
Amazon data is really clear separable
it's comparable to routers data set it's
very easy to separate classes with each
other while in a conversation it's not
that clear this class is not mutually
exclusive as we saw in the beginning but
also indeed it Chad and Cole is about
multiple things and in the review don't
have it and nevertheless the performance
of chat on shared data was very close to
human accuracy so human accuracy I will
not go into details how we actually
measured that this is a whole other
discussion but our estimations that
human accuracy on the first level is
from 61 to 71 percent on the second
level from 52 to 69 percent it's the
pessimistic first optimistic performance
so it's actually quite bad so there
there are clearly steps needed to
improve human accuracy however it wasn't
really feasible so business is very
reluctant to change the categories we
had so we decided to proceed with
automatic child classification and tons
of flow with the performance we
described and we understand with
creating new labels is costly so we
decided to in which investigate cheaper
labeling tagging alternatives using
unsupervised learning techniques and we
tried different things we tried out the
ADF idea with k-means dr back with
k-means average quarterback with k-means
we can we could think about many other
things but that's what we tried and when
evaluating techniques we mainly paint
paid intention to interpret ability how
easy it is to describe the clusters of
groups we found what how stable is that
algorithm and
how well does it fit two buckets bucketz
is another notion basically the supports
of crucification tree mapped into some
smaller categories and that's what we
wanted to map our clusters to so Lda we
used consume LGA implementation on
180,000
call transcripts and after finding the
most typical words per topic we actually
tried Lda on a different number of
topics to include and this seemed to be
the best which is still not that good
and we we were trying to map these
topics we show two buckets and buckets
our assurance fulfillment order
fulfillment installation internet sales
safe about cancellations TV and device
in proposition so if we look at the
words we see this is something about TV
internet and telephony and if you look
at this this is something about payments
with bucket assurance we can do the same
with all other topics this is a buckets
we get and we cannot relate that based
on the heat map at least we can start
from there and on the left side there
are DEA topics defined by all the
algorithm and there are buckets on
horizontal axis and we see they don't
map really nicely so the only bucket
that maps nicely is assurance but there
are a bunch of buckets missing like
hardware we have no Hardware bucket
assigned we couldn't find any which
looks like hardware and TV sales it's
also another packet we couldn't find
another problem without the game is that
it's not stable so if we feed the very
same documents in a different order to
LTA multiple times every time we get
different mapping of topics do two words
and each which results in different
topic definition so on the left side is
the first attempt on the right it is
another attempt and we see that we can
still find some topics on the left side
from the left side on the right side but
there are also some
that are not there anymore and there are
new topics which are emerged and there
is an argument that it probably will be
better if you have more documents but
however this issue seems to be hard to
fix there is a paper
what's wrong with topic modeling and how
to fix it so how to fix it part is
pretty hard so you can take a look into
that so the other thing was we tried is
dr. Beck with k-means we also tried the
other types of clustering we won't go
into that I will just explain this one
so it's against implementation of dr.
vac to generate document vectors we used
k-means with k plus passing
initialization with ten clusters we
tried also different number of clusters
just this seemed to be the best attempts
to group and we attempt to group the
documents by similarity of document
vector generated by dr. vac and we try
to understand the clusters but if we're
doing two things the heatmap and also
tf-idf to predict the clusters I use
decision tree for that and measure
feature importance so that if you look
at the heat map indeed again it doesn't
look that nice we cannot see possibly
which clusters are related to which
packets there is only one which is
really clear is assurance maybe we can
also say that custard 9 is something
about devices it's still very hard to
argue about it is so naturally created
clusters are very different from buckets
and if you look at the vehicle of words
that emerge actually may be clusters 0 &
9 makes sense but 7oz doesn't make sense
which look tag though quite well if you
look at the heat map and there is
another problem that emerges so if you
use the dr. vac for inferring new
documents so if you there is a new
document coming you want to classify
that in some particular cluster then it
you will not get consistent result dr.
Beck in vector inferring will give you
every time a different result you can
all of that by averaging like 20
attempts of inferring the vector you may
get something more or less stable but
it's costly and doesn't guarantee you
good results can be solved by creating
document vectors by computed vated
average or just average of world actors
belonging to the document which also
didn't give us any good results so it's
quite disappointing we can conclude that
unsupervised learning techniques even
though we haven't tried all of them
failed to come up with categories
meaningful and useful to do the business
and stability interpretability is also
an issue so you have possible
improvements guided Lda that we actually
feed in initialize the metrics for LJ in
a particular way so that it comes up
with categories we want to see and also
semi-supervised clustering with seeding
for instance if we if we define class if
we try to get cultures from document
vectors defined the average of all word
vectors we could initialize Center of
clusters as words belonging to some
ontology in the ocean so for instance if
we're talking about Internet there are
words like Xperia box modem Wi-Fi that
belongs to notion internet and then we
compute average of these words and
initialize class Center cross the
internet with that number with that
vector and so we decided actually to
look into ontology and together with the
business stakeholders we defined some
ontology dimensions and ontology terms
and we used word embeddings from word
Tyvek or also graph it's another thing
we tried to create ontology terms
synonyms and ontology and document
vectors and we wanted to validate
tagging techniques using Manley tag
evaluate a validation set so how well is
it mapped to them to what humans decided
as a tag for that particular document so
this
main pillars of the ontology we built so
the customer journey service and result
there are different steps of customer
journey different kind of services the
customer can call about different
results of the course and together with
the business by looking also tf-idf of
the of the terms belonging to particular
notions we could come up with these
words we also could come up with
synonyms of this world's based on word
Tyvek so basically by computing cosine
distance to the to the words so collect
informally it has similar words as
formally informally urge a plot so these
are things that can be considered as
synonyms and at some point of this of
these words so there are different
taking approaches we could use here so
first of all it's a vector similarity
approach we generate world vectors using
Ganz import work or glove we create
document and ontology vectors by
computed computing dated average of just
average of vectors of words belonging to
the document or ontology and we compute
after the similarity between these
vectors document ontology vectors and if
similarity exceeds the threshold we
assign the tag to the topic to the
document and there is another approach
topic word count approach so we generate
similar words for ontology terms we
count a number of ontology terms and
similar words in the document normalize
the count and assigned topic to document
if normalized context is the threshold
so I will show you in the details how
how it looks like this is a vector
similarity approach so this is the chat
you have seen and we can come up with a
document lecture in this in the
following way we take all the words we
take all the vector embeddings of all
the words with the complete average of
that or weighted average with the idea
of averaging this is a typical thing to
do and we
with a document vector that way the same
we can do for ontology this is an
ontology term these are all words belong
to ontology and we can this is
translated into English so we can
compute vector embedding and compute
ontology vectors that way by averaging
vectors of words and then when we have
them both we compare them using cotton
similarity you couldn't similarity
exceed the threshold and that complaint
will be unsigned in this case yeah there
are other similarity measure probably
for movers just insist something to look
into but we didn't go there so compute
cosine similarity is something we used
here the other approach is a topic word
count approach so this is again the same
job there are words that say this is
about conservation so canceled retention
I cancel again so word count would be
two words at I in ontology plus zero
eight times one the water tonight
retention which is a synonym of
cancellation and in this dataset and we
divided by number of words in a in a
document one half thousands as we
defined and then the score would be that
number times top equates so because we
know some topics have more words and
other topics you want to correct for
that so this is the way we correct this
can be probably done in better ways but
that's what we tried so far and if score
exceed the threshold then it the
cancellation tag will be assigned the
same with internet subscriptions so we
have internet world here and some other
words here and in this way we can define
whether that internet will be assigned
to this to this chat the important thing
to mention here is that when we looked
at the calls and chats and try to use
super best approach we assumed that on
there there is only one label that can
be assigned to call a chat here we
assume there can be multiple tags
assigned to a to a cello call so these
are the results for vector similarity so
where we computed the similarity between
toldja terms and them and the documents
and we looked at the precision recall
and accuracy per tag and in the end we
measure the total f1 score there are
some defined categories it was never
assigned this is a bad sign so it looks
like we need to look at these particular
categories and improve them somehow it
makes sense for instance custom
information is something that people
talk about all the time doesn't matter
about what kind of topic you're
interested in when you call in KPM we
always ask you what is your postcode
house number and therefore these terms
belong to custom information this name
is information or complain it's it's
sometimes hard to define the other
approach gave us a bit better result so
this is a topic word count results we
have better average of one score and
there are no ill-defined categories
however the results are also not always
the best yeah so we can say that
ontology doesn't give us the results we
were exactly hoping for it it gives us a
van score lower than we thought to have
so the problem here is that our ontology
categories that we defined with the
business are still quite vague and it's
very hard to come up with a good good
categories which are mutually exclusive
this is the key point here so if you sit
with the stakeholder you have the same
problem if you want to sit with the
stakeholders you really need to be
strict to them and make sure that the
human accuracy that it's very high that
when people define categories they have
a very high chance to agree with each
other on that point so there are
possible improvements that can be done
one told you that we're gonna look into
using part of speech parsers for Dutch
there are frog and space you to define
the phrases meant to be still after
pragmatics and it's a typical Dutch
phrases that we could be interested in
and use phrase and bearings for instance
first texts of Facebook is something
what we could could use to do that and
indeed improve ontology categories
ontology terms nevertheless that we did
not achieve the results you were hoping
for we actually still can believe it can
work the main advantage of applying
anthologies is that it requires ten
times less label data then a supervised
learning algorithm so we believe that
validation sort of 5000 can be good
enough to evaluate how good is your
labeling using anthologies and for CNM
that I showed in the beginning you need
at least 50,000 calls a child to get
good results so it's a big cost
difference as well and time difference
I told it's important to define the
categories well when a human accuracy is
high and the procedure I would advise
you if you have a comparable problem and
you have no labels whatsoever of the
data you can first define define that
with the business be very strict at
their major exclusives and start
labeling the data when you agreed on the
human that the human accuracy was good
enough if you gather at five thousand
then go on with ontology
and see whether you get successful good
results if it's not successful you can
always proceed and label more data and
proceed with CNN which we which actually
shows good results and that's basically
the approach we're gonna take now the
project I was telling you is project for
consumer market for business markets
right now we have no categories
whatsoever so we are planning a lot of
workshops with business stakeholders to
define the categories for each level we
reiterate
compute human accuracy and proceed only
if we are satisfied with that and if we
gather five thousands we will receive it
and told you for that notion and then if
it's not working nicely we will go
further thank you yeah if you have any
questions please ask ask me and we are
hiring so if you interested in text
mining and what I was telling here
please said yeah or anything else please
come up to our booth we have the booth
here so thank you
[Applause]
very nice talk Maria thank you very much
so we have some minutes left for
questions does anybody have a question
for thank you for the talk I would like
to ask you so one of the problems that
maybe you're facing and as a result
models cannot differentiate between
categories is that the signal of the
nature of the problem which is the
category is also mixed with a lot of
other information about the mood of the
color or the way he expresses himself
which is very non-standard but I would
expect that your agents are trained to
reply in a way that is more or less
standard so have you tried isolating
only the answers of the agent and then
training unknown that actually we tried
both isolating only customer information
only agent it's not getting much better
okay unfortunately any other questions
actually there was a talk in the morning
about text mining where he uses a salmon
cutter to get just most important
sentence from a Dutch text did you I
don't know if if you maybe going to try
this try the actually summarization but
it was for different purposes when agent
has interaction to the customer he wants
to know whether he the customer already
had interaction before and it's very
hard to go through the whole chat so we
could use summary to to give that
information but faster and we basically
were testing the quality of summary
based on classification results on
summary verses the whole text but I
don't see the summary can improve these
performance anyhow thanks any other
questions we have like two minutes left
it's just very simple question when you
show the results for LGA and the first
part of your analysis what kind of text
pre-processing did you do oh it's very
different things mostly a minimization
so we try to remove as much of names and
numbers not remove but replaced by
placeholder and remove some stop words
or not remove them and compare the
results it did not improve very much
there are some stop words in the O
categories which is I don't know if you
try to express tchen maybe hey so you're
using CN NS or heavy charge Rs TM or
some kind of what is the best okay thank
all right thank you very much Thank You
Maria please give it a lot of arm
applause
[Applause]